you all know about the office of
censorship in the united states
the office of censorship was an
emergency wartime agency agency set up
in the u.s from december 19th 1941 to
aid in the censorship of all
communications coming into and out of
the united states including its
territories in the philippines the
efforts of the office of office of
censorship to balance the protection of
sensitive war-related information with
the constitutional freedoms of the press
is considered largely successful
oh largely successful it was amazing
thank you wikipedia for telling us about
the successful office of censorship
it's just loose lips perfect
the fact is look at that thanks ike the
sensors
why would we not see the same thing in a
world war three scenario or even let's
maybe wouldn't even call it world war
three maybe we enter into full-scale war
with just russia alone and and nato why
would we not see this same effort we saw
this effort with with kova exactly i was
just about to say didn't we have the
biden administration pressuring social
media companies to remove information
that they consider to be misinformation
but i'm saying escalated to the next
degree the fcc commissioner nominee uh
who who is up i can't remember her name
right now uh but they're trying to block
it and this is exactly her we just saw
we just went through two years of
understanding
what it was
that the amount of people the you know
the critical mass amount of people would
go along with and they ratcheted things
up and they ratcheted things up in the
name of crisis in the name of national
emergency and they just got had a huge
system-wide test of everything that that
they could roll out without seeing any
meaningful pushback whatsoever and in
canada they're about a year ahead of us
and you know what i'll add this tim
maybe this is a little bit of a black
pill here but i don't think we'd have
another office of censorship because we
don't need one yeah we already have
google exactly they just flip a switch
you're done or alphabet rather it's even
more terrifying they have like 13
companies which are like ai we are the
alphabet
alphabet is the name of the company it's
funny because we also have the alphabet
agencies right it's not a coincidence
yeah they're probably like it's like
let's we're kind of like one of those
alphabet companies and they're like yeah
we are alphabet we'll just call
ourselves alphabet they're you know
i wonder if google was you know doing
all this really great work and they were
like don't be evil guys and then some
you know
some bureaucratic administrative state
guy walks in and says we're taking over
and the first thing we got to do is guys
that that that slogan don't be evil
we're evil come on
that's the new model that they were
trying to get rid of a double negative
when you say don't be evil you people
hear evil evil evil and then they just
start thinking it and be but when you
write it and you read it it interacts
with your brain differently than when
you hear it no ian they're just evil
it's just well that might be true too i
mean there's different people that own
the company now like larry and sergey
were pretty cool but man did that thing
get out of here aren't they still in
alphabet though partially i just saw
that uh sergei sold a bunch of stock
last july i think maybe it was larry one
of them sold like i don't know how many
millions of dollars worth of stock they
want to control what you think
they need to rally
people behind this this is why they got
so triggered when i said i despise
appeals to emotion because i'm directly
calling out what is very obvious
propaganda crying translators
no no hold on there a minute man the job
of a translator is to translate why
would you hire someone or keep someone
on the job if they're crying you'd be
like like i said before you'd be like oh
no he's crying let's get him into the
break room and have some coffee and take
a breath and get someone else in there
who can do their job you know and
because it's manipulation so follow up
with what you said seamus like we don't
really need an office of censorship they
closed the office of censorship in 1945
when the war ended but basically then
they started the liberal economic order
within like eight months and i think
they just winded in all that censorship
ability into this new spy network of
five eyes or you know the global
military industrial i mean it's
interesting because
for a long time you had what was it the
three and then the five major networks
that everyone got all of their
information from and that was wonderful
for them because it was very easy to
control what people were seeing and
hearing and then the internet popped up
and now it seemed as if there was a
threat people could get their
information from everywhere but uh
fortunately for them and unfortunately
for us a lot of that power has been
consolidated and we're not quite back in
the same position but in some ways we're
getting there i'm i'm optimistic on some
level that we won't quite be able to get
back to that but at the end of the day
it doesn't really matter if people are
too scared to speak the truth and
most seem to be yeah self-censorship is
as effective as as you know forceful
censorship in a way yeah well it's
interesting there have been studies
which have suggested that people are
better capable or would prefer to endure
physical pain over social rejection wow
yeah uh and it's
psychological suffering i know
psychological suffering in general and
so if if people
if people feel as if they are being
rejected by the group
or they fear being rejected by the group
for stating something they're going to
be very likely to keep quiet in the same
way that they'd be likely to keep quiet
if they thought someone would physically
aggress upon them for speaking out so
this is what the stasi got into towards
the you know everybody you watch the
lives of others um one of the greatest
movies on on communist surveillance
systems and the programs that they had
people informing each other in east
germany so that was the 1960s by the
1970s 1980s the stasi wasn't running
these massive surveillance programs
anymore and they weren't running these
massive incarceration programs the way
they were uh depicted in that film what
they ended up doing was they realized
that if you were a dissident if you were
someone who's a troublemaker they had a
problem with you uh it's exactly what
shame was just laying out first thing
they would do is start to ostracize you
and then they would start to shame you
they would smear you in the media they
would drag your name through the mud
they would essentially blacklist you and
they would make it so that the social
shame upon everyone else of even
associating with you would be enough to
destroy you and it was actually much
cheaper and far more effective than
throwing you in prison and making a
potential martyr of you how i i i i i
wonder about this like how is a show
like this possible in these you know
we're literally saying that partly
because it's a group of us winging a
prayer haven't you haven't you had the
swat team come like five times yeah i
mean too i mean six i mean so how is it
possible it is possible for now but look
at the forces look at the forces trying
to shut it down i still feel like we're
in the prelude you know yeah i think a
lot of it has to do with enough peop a
big group a large enough group of people
communicating these ideas makes it hard
to stop the idea if it's one person
alone in their room on a webcam then you
know yeah get swatted you know and
that's why
that's why when i see censorship you
know i do speak out against it even if
it's someone i don't particularly agree
with or don't particularly like or
support you know the idea that one
person or one entity just has this
ability to to blanket wipe out all
communications right that's actually a
much bigger issue than some idiot on a
podcast that i don't listen to
yeah the vulnerability of our system
isn't talked about enough from comet
strikes to floods to earthquakes to
volcanic super eruptions to just a just
a power outage from a solar flare or
like uh
or like uh well you're seeing these for
example you're seeing these stories that
so google and apple pay are shut down in
russia and so suddenly because they went
cashless now people are saying wait how
do i get on the subway how do i pay for
things in stores how do i do this and so
we've outsourced all you know if you're
signed up for all these things now
you're outsourcing your variability to
function in society to silicon valley so
that gives them that i mean this is
we're talking about sovereign power we
can artificially never go cashless
we can never go cashless we can never go
i mean that has to be within our dna as
like a fight to the death we can never
be a cashless society so you think we
need a federal some sort of federal
power that d gains that currency
valuable i think you need a physical
even not necessarily cash but i think we
have to have a system that you can have
a physical commodity that i can hide
under my bed because if jack doesn't
like me and he's able to call the guys
who are on apple pay and say shut down
his account if i can't go to the grocery
store if i can't buy things if my credit
quote-unquote is stuck in my phone and
my phone is useless because jack doesn't
like me
then i am i'm i'm a powerless i have no
agency left you're lucky i like you
you're lucky
i want to add a caveat to something i
said earlier i wanted to pull up
information about what i referenced um
what what i was referencing it's not a
study about social rejection versus
physical pain there's there's two
articles i'm looking at here but
basically the idea is that um they have
shown that we process social pain in the
same part of the brain that we process
physical pain with and um there's also a
very interesting perspective from uh
psychology and psychologists i i'm not
sure if it's the consensus or not but
basically that emotional pain is in many
ways worse than physical pain because it
can be triggered by memories in a way
that physical pain cannot so for example
i can remember something from the past
that hurt me or was difficult for me and
uh the emotional trauma of that can sort
of return whereas if i remember a
physical injury i'm not going to
literally feel that physical pain in
quite the same way wow yeah emotional
pain can make you like adopt a posture
which can then bring on a certain sort
of tension leading to injury unless you
dream it have you ever dreamed i had a
dream where you have physical pain and
you wake up and like something hurts oh
yeah all the time interesting yeah all
the time if you're ever dreaming you
want to get out close your eyes really
tight till they hurt and then when you
open them you'll be awake
getting some so i found an account that
has some backstory on how this nuclear
power plant situation uh started so
apparently they're saying that and again
caveat caveat caveat right fog of war
focal board grain assault blah blah blah
that they're saying that the russians
rolled up and demanded that the power
plant surrender and that the defenders
of the plant surrender um they said we
have overwhelming force you should
surrender you should stand down so that
we can take over this plant and do so
peacefully the defenders refused and
that's when the firefight started wow so
those were russian soldiers on the
ground you so there's russia it was
russian soldiers on the ground and it
looked like there were defenders and if
you look at that clip um that a few
people have have pulled out of that live
stream you it looks like you can
actually see tracer fire rounds being
fired from the roof at the russian
artillery
okay
and then so that was there incoming
artillery
well the artillery is on the ground
right next to the power plant
yes oh are they firing that artillery at
the power plant across the street well
at the defenders wow that close range
yes wow that's insane yeah that's what
you're seeing in in the video okay i
thought stuff was coming from out and
then i thought i saw missiles flying
outward from there but that wasn't what
i was those are just shells okay
so we actually just watched a battle
take place in real time yes we did
that's kind of amazing yes we actually
did i remember
siege even a couple modern um feats of
social media the first was when the
al-qasam brigades in palestine were
firing rockets into israel and the idf
and the alaskan brigades were tweeting
at each other in a flame war yeah during
a hot war
and a lot of people actually laughing
there because it was like you know al
qasam was like we will wipe you out and
the idf was like try it we'll stop you
and i'm like they're tweeting at each
other but then there was um in the
middle east
we got a
video a gopro attached to a to a tank to
um
to a tank
and uh the soldiers who were shooting
back at it or being fired upon were also
they also had gopros and so the footage
made it to the internet where
researchers were able to find both
perspectives and put it in a single
video where you could see
both sides of a conflict online crazy
stuff yeah could you hear both the
voices of the people from either side
you couldn't hear anything from the tank
because the camera's outside and the
people are inside but you could hear the
people on there well have you seen the
the chechens and the azov leaders are
now sending are cutting videos about
each other about talking about
essentially how they're gearing up for
this massive fight in mariopol wow and
so those are kind of you're considered
your most brutal fighters on either side
i mean and for azov i mean you can find
very quickly uh videos of azov
committing beheadings committing
crucifixions of ethnic russians uh
chechens i think goes without saying um
extremely extremely brutal or if you
know anything about the battle of grozny
or the cheshire wars and so uh the
leaders of kardarov who is the leader of
the chechens is now coming in to he's
pro putin fighting for the russians
going in specifically targeting that as
of battalion and the last some of the
messages i was getting
uh from a contact that i have that's uh
active duty right now was that they were
you know possibly trying to get as off
to at least surrender and they were
saying hey if you we just want the city
we don't need we don't need to kill all
of you just leave and we'll let you go
out to the west well you can go to levi
we won't even you know we will let you
surrender and just just evacuate and of
course as i was saying no we saw video
as of uh remember the battalion dipping
bullets and pigs lard right and then
saying we're gonna get because a lot of
chechens are muslim and uh that's also
very concerning because
religion into it which from ufc have the
greatest he's like a governor isn't he a
mayor or something no i'm thinking of uh
there's something into the two brothers
right yeah there's a mma fighter that's
like a a mayor of a city in russia right
now russia klitschko klitschko that's
that's that's ukraine that's your crew
no that's no that's yeah that's and
they're boxers that's completely oh yeah
i got it a third right thanks
no no fighters of some sort
by the way i noticed you guys mentioned
called it a uh uh state of the union i
can't in good faith it's a campaign
speech
at the end he did say the state of the
union was strong and it's strong because
the people are strong strong technically
you could argue it was a state of the
union because you know very end nobody's
actually nobody's even questioning why
putin is doing this now have you noticed
that yeah everyone kind of gets it so
that's so true that narrative isn't even
the narrative is okay you you can ask
why is he doing this right and i think
there's a lot of
clearly a huge debate on that and he's
not been very clear about it in some
ways you know he has a stated purposes
but we think there's probably some more
than that but nobody's asking why now
everybody kind of gets that yeah this
this is the time well he actually so
what happened was biden pulled him aside
and really intimidated him uh and made
it very clear that there would be
repercussions if he tried to uh take the
hearts and minds of the iranian people
and said all right i won't did he
whisper he's here okay whispering
don't do it
i i want to mention this too uh ian um
your point about it being more of like a
campaign speech i completely agree which
is why we we just released a cartoon
about this today for for freedom tunes
if you guys want to check that out just
want to plug that because that's um very
much along those lines when he said he
was going to help cure what do you say
was going to cure
he said we're going to end cancer as we
know it what are you talking about i
don't know as we know it yeah
they're going to change definitions
he's going to do gain of function
research
he's just going to change the definition
of the word
he's like so i fulfilled my promise
called up miriam webster and said you
know put another word in there and now
it's different as we know it's a
different word different word
he was talking about astrology cancer
he's talking about these people oh man i
just can't stand the camera i think when
i think people who hate trump and
there's those people who dislike him i
think when they would hear trump tell a
story i can imagine what their reaction
was like this guy is so full of himself
he's such an idiot blah blah blah when
biden told that story i looked at putin
and i said i don't think you have a soul
and he looked at me and said we
understand each other did anyone believe
that that actually happened
right does it mean
so trump tells the story and they're
over the top and there is silly biden
tells the story and even his supporters
are like yeah dude that didn't happen
was a bad dude who was asked about that
i said i said hey esther i say hey putin
get off the diving board or i'll come
and drag you up an embers nbc interview
with putin they asked him about that he
was like i i don't i don't remember it
was a diplomacy thing so he insulted me
like that i don't know why he did that
that's just like a weird thing to say
it's like vladimir putin was banging the
razor blood on the curb it rusty
bang his nuclear weapon on the curb get
it rusty put it in a barrel we'll also
like call it esther williams or
something
i said you get off
yeah i just i i find it hilarious that
with trump
trump was like if you touch the ukraine
i will nuke must go like a very real
concrete threat and vines like
you don't have a soul man
okay but it's like
okay what was this what does this mean
i have no soul
let's take ukraine now okay he's like oh
no joe biden will not like me if i do
this
like i've never had a soul i'm glad you
recognized that
putin
like biden says that you ain't got a
soul man then he walks away and putin
confused looks over to like sergey
lavrov and says he says i have no soul
he goes yes
let's take ukraine no exactly but do do
you think like what an unbelievably
insane thing for him to ever even if he
did say that do you think that um do you
think that somebody on the international
stage wants their enemy to think they
have a soul do you want to be seen as a
bleeding heart type no no i mean biden
does no yeah exactly it's just so
ridiculous is it like oh this is so bad
for public relations people will think i
am not nice guy yeah this would make a a
good like which actually would be the
down downfall of putin instead of russia
people didn't think he was a nice guy
fourth they thought he was a nice guy
good
comic would be like
trump saying i'll nuke moscow and putin
looking to lavrov and being like let's
hold back for a minute then biden saying
you have no soul and i'll be like okay
we're good no it's only like trump gives
a direct threat of violence and binds
like you're mean man
don't attack me in my vulnerable spots
which are here here and here
he's like hey man it'd be really mean if
you did biden actually did that yeah
he's like you ain't got a soul man so
i'm gonna show you a list of all the
places you better not attack there you
go uh just that one's most important i
trust you
that's crazy man it's a fundamental risk
misreading of this you know
and you can dig into some of the
philosophical aspects of this where you
know when you look at the united states
in in many ways at least in terms of how
our regime is
positioned you know we are it's athens
and sparta right so we are the sea power
you know we want commerce we want trade
we want these sort of globalized rules
we want to be able to do business with
the rest of the world whereas russia
predominantly is a land power they are
land-based power we were just talking
earlier about how they have so many
issues for them to be able to uh get to
see so they have that that mindset of
strength over everything um power over
everything might makes right um and it
does have a deeper sense of cultural
traditionalism whereas in the u.s it is
this more you know sort of
progress you know small p progressivism
of this enlightened oh we can always be
better we can rise above right these are
two very
these are two ideas that are in not only
philosophical contention but spiritual
contention as well and i think if we
fail to understand that we are
completely misreading the situation not
only and bill rojo had a great article
about how we've completely misread
russia's strategy in the war i think
that's obvious but at this point right
russia isn't losing just because they
didn't take kiev in the first 24 hours
but i think we completely misread the
way russian leaders are even just even
the way that they think so if you can't
understand how or appreciate how your
adversary thinks how can you ever
attempt to get ahead of their decision
cycle get inside their ooda loops or
even predict their future moves it's so
true lauren southern made a great point
about this yesterday when referring to
china or two days ago we have no idea
how the chinese think but they know
exactly how we think because they go to
the un and say the united states of
america is racist and they don't care
about black lives matter i know china
doesn't care about minorities china uh
in order to sell the the new star wars
film in china they had to reduce the
size of a black actor on the poster
yeah i get messages from time time from
chinese citizens that are like uh ccp is
not china and so if you really want to
understand chinese yeah read the romance
of the three kingdoms or watch the movie
and then read the book yeah but i think
i think i know what you're saying and i
agree with you a hundred percent but i
would go even a little further
in in right now in america it is not
just like we have a small p
progressivism
it was not long ago that the american
flag on a nike sneaker caused uproars
yeah right so not only do we not have we
have a progressivism we are
intentionally led by this administration
quite frankly or the progressive left we
are intentionally destroying the pillars
of our foundation yeah and the smallest
things and we've talked a lot about this
on the show the smallest things that
unify us like like the national anthem
well you should be able to protest that
and this little moment well that should
be up for debate and the
george washington maybe we should change
the name of the school so i think if
you're putin and and this is not uh you
know shilling for him at all don't get
me wrong but if you are him and his
administration and and russian power and
you look at the west and say they don't
even respect their george washington
right why why are we afraid of these
people right like
we changed the name of of abraham
lincoln school in california do you
think but do you think maybe it's
possible that xi jinping feels
threatened by how introspective we are
no doubt and how diverse our army is
yeah that was it wait wait till he sees
our diversity it is exactly oh well we
got a question about that all of our
soldiers are doing tick tock
invaded videos saw the threat of the
west diversity trainings and he was
sweating bullets and he was like we have
to invade do this now yeah once they all
once they all learn about diversity
inclusivity and equity we're done now
what you're seeing is so we've we've
become quite decadent in in this sort of
30 years since the fall of the soviet
union this idea of fukuyama's you know
end of history and everyone's going to
adopt so instead of thinking that our
values were western or that they were
derived from the bible um that they're
you know greco-roman
legal practice european law et cetera
principles enlightenment what you all of
that no no we decided that these were
universal principles and that we could
go on these nation building projects
around the world and that we could
impose our way of thinking on everyone
because our way of thinking was natural
and we don't even need all this history
as you're describing to back it up that
we've you know that we've advanced from
or that we've developed from no no no no
these are just the universal values and
now our job now is to proselytize the
world and evangelicalize them to our way
of thinking so the first place of course
that we're going to try that is
afghanistan right because we're going to
turn you know kandahar into california
and we never once sat back and thought
you know maybe the rest of the world
doesn't want those things or maybe they
don't think that way and so that's why
you're seeing now instead of actually
focusing on the things that would make
our country strong like energy strong
currency we do need a strong u.s dollar
by the way if the us dollar falls off
its perch that's really going to be bad
for a lot of americans because i think a
lot of people out there that are living
paycheck to paycheck that don't have a
lot of savings you know you always see
those studies out there and i'm sure
it's much worse now about how many
people have less than you know five
thousand dollars two thousand dollars in
their checking accounts um what happens
to them when that checking account
becomes you completely worthless
overnight because the us dollar loses
its world reserve status they'll print
like another eight trillion and try and
just give everyone four grand to get
them
so you're seeing you're seeing now a
complete reworking of the world order
and that's why
even as horrific as these scenes are
that are coming out of ukraine um the
long-term implications of this might
actually be worse yeah because
unipolarity is gone the international
rules-based order is gone multi-polarity
is returning that's going to be a huge
problem for us because remember even you
know we talk about the swift system okay
let's you know pull the nuclear plant
and kick russia off the swift system
well the swiss system only works because
it's backed by the us dollar if russia
is already planning to get off the
dollar then they don't need it
yeah well isn't it interesting oh no no
please no no well it's interesting how
we like to play philanthropists and act
like we are exporting western values
around the world and helping people live
better lives because we care about the
the downtrodden one in many
circumstances it's either militaristic
intervention or economic bullying to
force our way of life onto other people
even in countries where they're not
ready for it or ready for it is the
wrong term because some of the things
that we tried important to these
countries aren't things people should
ever be ready for uh i find it
fascinating and i don't think it's a
coincidence that the intellectual
founders of neoconservatism were former
marxists and look at the neoconservative
mission look what we tried to do in
afghanistan
oh we're going to completely and
fundamentally restructure a culture at
the barrel of a gun and this country
this entire nation with a history that
we don't even care to understand is
going to bow before the order we have
determined is the culmination of history
which is how they conceptualize
democracy now instead of marxism as
neoconservatives because we ordered them
to it the barrel of a gun and were able
to restructure their thinking it's crazy
dude i watched i don't even want to get
i was looking at a picture of the bath
party so it didn't work by the way bath
party and you just see these young frat
boys
it's too long of a conversation to go
into now check it out though saddam
hussein bath party image and you see
saddam is a young rambunctious youth
that guy was a nut well the thing that i
find bizarre about this whole
conversation from the 30 000 foot level
especially are we invading do we not
invade what is the role of nato etc etc
it was not very long ago that like a
million and a half hutus and tutsis and
rwanda slaughtered each other with a
machete and the west just sat there and
watched it and said wow that's bad i
mean like literally over a million five
hundred thousand and the majority of
them were hacked to death and we just
sat there and were like with chinese
michelle that's that's bad but there was
so i don't understand
should should we intervene when there's
evil happening as a philosophy i
understand that position but but we're
ready to jump into the ukraine but no
one wanted to go to rwanda so what's the
difference thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you